[Music]
foreign
rebirth is currently out on Netflix
right now and yeah this might be kind of
a spoiler video so it's up to you to
watch it we are going to discuss eight
of the different kaijus seen in that
series although they stated that Gamera
will fight only five of them making six
in total but they are actually two more
so let's get to it let's start with
Gamera so a hundred thousand years prior
an ancient civilization utilized Gamera
for genocide however he was stolen and
turned against them before they used him
disrupting their plan for human genocide
and population control this gamara is
colored in a dark greenish with bright
bluish highlights on its shell it
possesses large green eyes and a pointed
snout its long tail features small
spikes on top and his hands are large
with black claws it also has two tops as
well as sharp teeth and it appears to be
60 meters or 200 feet tall unlike the
jacket plates covering its characters
its shell consists of smooth plates
similar to the heisei version of the
character when gamara takes flights or
swims its front limbs transform into
flipper-like Wings unlike the earlier
versions bright blue flames emit from
the leg holes of its shell and the backs
of its flippers for supersonic flight so
it also possesses various Powers
including flight flame projection EMP
shockwaves a fiery Vanishing hand a
shell saw a jet barrier gravitational
control and aurelium energy Cannon which
was its Ultimate Weapon and an energy
feel as well as the ability to
reincarnate making it op here in this
show
next Gauss so in this series the origins
of Gauss is like the other kaijus
genetically and biologically engineered
by a group of ancient human
civilizations a hundred thousand years
ago they wanted to rid the world of
humanity and establish a master race but
the plans were fought by Gamera in the
beginning of the series it is described
that Gauss have eggs and these were
discovered in a mining base in New
Guinea and when these eggs hatch it led
to a swarm of baby gals wreaking havoc
in the Philippines and later in Japan
and they grew in size gradually and
Falls depending on the food Souls this
Kaiju is overall Crimson or red in color
and has two bat-like wings with two legs
that end in sharp claws it also has a
prehensile tail and a head which is
triangular in shape with two eyes and a
pair of horns it can also shoot out a
laser beam like power from its mouth
that is called the supersonic scalpel
the biggest Gauss was smaller than
Gamera and would have been around 30
meters or 100 feet tall in height gauze
here is a small species and highly
predatorial
the third Kaiju Jagger this is another
catch that was a rival to Gamera and it
was stated to be 60 meters or 200 feet
long its Origins are not explicitly
stated but we can infer that it was
engineered by the organization called
the foundation the Eustis foundation in
the beginning we were able to see
several of its eggs being held in a
large tube and when they were released
the juvenile Jaggers began to eat
everything in sight even cannibalizing
on themselves with the strongest one
becoming the gigantic Jagger that faces
off against Gamera it looks to be of a
dinosaur in appearance but a mix of
several species it has a Triceratops
like head with a gigantic Crest and a
single large horn on its top it also had
several pairs of tusks on his face
it possesses a spinosaurin like Sail on
its back and a long prehensile tale that
ended in a sharp Spike that it uses to
stab its enemies and victims it also has
large Claws and a mouth full of sharp
teeth it was very agile for its size but
was killed when Gamera put his flaming
Fizz inside of her and burn it from the
inside and then ending with a flaming
shot
the fourth Kaiju zigra zigra is a
sikaiju resembling a dragon-like manta
ray it has a tough silvery gray skin a
wings with claws and a sharp head with
serrated teeth zigra can swim very fast
reaching over 200 knots underwater and
even faster by creating bubbles it uses
echolocation underwater and can
withstand missile attacks while it is
still susceptible to EMP shock waves
that can disorient it and it is also
vulnerable to fire fire attacks by
Gamera ziggurus head can Pierce through
ships easily its long tail can stretch a
long way even from land to the Shoreline
its size is stated to be 130 meters long
but the tail can extend to several
hundreds of extra meters on land it
moves slowly using its fins and legs
while it can glide in the air with its
wing-like fins it does not do so in an
agile manner zigra can also shoot an
indigo energy beam from his mouth but it
was killed by Gamera with a flaming shot
the fifth Kaiju gairon gyron is a Kaiju
that looks like a four-legged metallic
monster with a dark blue spine-like skin
four legs with five silver claws on each
and a big silver blade on its head that
is as long as its body its head blade
can be opened up to reveal three sharp
parts that it can move with his muscles
gyron uses this blade to cut through
anything even other monsters it can also
dig into the ground very quickly and was
said to be a Subterranean life form that
emerged from an underground mine gyron
is super flexible and can stretch his
body like rubber it also uses this
ability to attack and reach lengths of
up to 100 meters or 328 feet it's really
good at moving around and even jump from
long distances in the air gyron has a
special attack where it can shoot
shuriken-like blades from its tail using
energy from its back and spines and they
come out from the head blade like a
railgun but in the end it was sliced in
half by gamerai using his shell so
attack
the sixth Kaiju virus this kaju looks
like a mix between a squid and an
octopus as well as being twice the
height of Gamera around 90 meters or 328
feet and even longer when taking the
tentacles into consideration it has a
dark yellow skin and a mouth with sharp
teeth and small tentacles on each side
of its head it also has something like
insect-like Jaws it possesses 8
tentacles and at the end of each one of
them there is a mouth with pointy teeth
it also has a shell on its head that can
open up into three parts and inside of
it there's a special Cannon called the
lightning of hemutin virus can do some
cool things it can make electricity with
its head shell and use aestheticals to
shock its enemies it can create an
energy shield to protect itself from
gamera's attacks when it opens its head
shell it can charge up the lightening of
hemutan and shoot a powerful beam of
electricity that can even reach into
space it can also stretch out its
tentacles real far to grab things like I
try to do so with the foundation Supply
shuttle and also to beat Gamera to a
pulp and here's a fun one by flipping
upside down it can use its head shell
and tentacles to fly like a spaceship
using something called gravitones and
anti-gravity
number seven as Gauss genetically
engineered in 1989 and lived within a
body of virus until it was released upon
the kaiju's death as gal stands out
among its counterparts with several
unique features including having Four
Eyes instead of two a distinctive
two-pronged elongated tongue and
membranes between its horns at a head
and a dark red pigmentation on his body
one of its remarkable abilities is
enhanced growth achieved by consuming
viruses remains enabling as gas to reach
towering Heights surprising even gamara
even twice the size and maybe 90 meters
or 300 feet tall while its size deprived
of flying it however acquired the
ability of Swift underwater movement
like ziggura its durability also
increased significantly with a tough
hype that can withstand missile attacks
and tank fire power like Jagger and
gyron S Gauss with a signature Sonic
beam a magenta colored energy beam
blasting from its mouth moreover it
gained gravity enhanced Sonic beam after
consuming service utilizing its head
fins to generate gravitation energy for
devastating land-based attacks notably
as Gauss possesses the unique ability to
inject RNA viruses capable of reverting
other Kaiju to their original forms and
roles and it injects these into its
Target using its specialized tongue it
was the backup plan for the foundation
to use this foundation and it was so
powerful that only the ultimate attack
of gamara was able to kill it
and lastly number eight Toto this is the
small reincarnated baby Gamera that is a
foot tall and cute as baby gamara
is very similar to the large Gamera and
bears a resemblance to Toto but it is a
lighter green than his adult
counterparts uh coloration with white
claws instead of black and also stubby
Tusk well it's still a juvenile it also
has a sharper beak with no teeth and
three ropes of small bumps on the top of
its head so that's all we have to say
about Toto anyway I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video on the 8
different kaijus in the Gamera rebirth
series anyway do hit that like button
for support and subscribe but most of
all smash that Bell icon for regular
updates on new videos here on this
channel till the next one take care fam